take the entire universe count every
photon that's coming from every star and
add it all up that's how much energy is
released by this event it's the most
energetic Astrophysical object ever
observed since the Big Bang you worry
that in any complicated experiment like
this that you may have made a discovery
but you're not sure that this cover is
really true and I mean that there's many
situations in my life what that's
happened we've been through a whole
series of exercises to figure out what
this was and many of them underlying
them are sucked out
we're like could we have caused this by
our own ignorance or anything from
accidents to you know to malpractice
there's this wonderful thing that goes
around you know it is there some evil
genius that has laid us into us this
evil genius gets to be more and more
complicated and more and more skilled as
you delve into this in a deeper and
deeper way so it's not just one evil
genius it's a multiple et group of evil
geniuses every check we've done has kind
of come back saying no this really came
from some Astrophysical origin we
believe I mean nothing in the instrument
that we found so far could have done
this and nothing that we have found so
far indicates that it could have been
some intentional or accidental or
malicious injection and so then you
start almost believing it and that's
pretty cool
I think the remarkable thing is not so
much that we saw a gravitational wave I
mean that's remarkable enough but it
isn't the real centerpiece of this whole
discovery that centerpiece is the fact
that we saw a particular source that
nature seems to have given us it's the
best source we put it imagine it's the
source that says Einstein is right on
every goddamn detail almost in other
words it's this is a source that doesn't
require any other physics than general
relativity let's think of that
now I recall last fall rumors started
circulating all around that you all had
seen a gravitational waves and that was
probably I started to hear about this
October November something of that sort
first of what was your feeling when
these rumors started to get out there
you guys had not announced yet but yet
there was this growing anticipation was
that exciting was it irritating
irritating irritating why because yeah
if you want to make the case when you do
something like this you want to make the
case right and we weren't ready to make
it right so it was very irritating and
worrying yeah because if it did come out
and we had to defend it we weren't ready
I think there was a reason look sorry
there's a real process for us as well
from the time we saw the first signal to
believing that it really was a faster
physical origin and not some thing in
the detector I mean was your initial
thought that it that it was not real
very much more rhythm let me let me say
something may not be no modest now like
you know it's really how yourself know
let me tell you we're playing all of us
I think everybody here and I could
disagree with me now raise your hand
however it's actually is it look just
too good that was the thing no no I'm
very serious about it I mean here we
gone you mean if someone was going to
fake a signal this is okay we're taking
it in a second but let us say what it
looked like when you first saw it I mean
we've gone through a lot of stages
expecting signals that we be just
marginal yeah and we had gone and made
lovely algorithms to be able look at the
data very carefully and here is this
thing that came on in the morning and it
you didn't have to do much filtering I
mean you could look at it with your eye
with a blurred out a lot of computing
it's almost nothing more than if you had
a radio and you had a base in the travel
control you got a little just thing of
it so you could hear a little better see
it a little better and that's all we had
to do to see this waveform that was the
thing that made us all suspicious
you